uh there were some interesting items
purchased through our amazon link over
the last week of course if you ever shop
on amazon what I suggest is first stop
by david pakman.com slash amazon and
then everything you buy will send us a
little kickback a mr. robot episodes
being streamed by many in our audience
I'm completely up to speed on this show
and Louis every time I recommend mr.
robot to someone they say what what
channel is that on and I say oh it's on
USA and immediately people start
trash-talking saying USA has no good
shows and then as soon as they watch the
show they come back to me apologetic
saying David I'm sorry I'm I'm really
sorry that I critiqued you for
recommending a USA show because the show
is fantastic yes I I still have yet to
see it to be honest but uh uh I'm
getting there I just have so much on my
plate right now when it comes to to
television and Jason you've watched some
episodes of mr. robot although after I
recommended it to Jason he started on
season two which is I would start at
season one personally but you're are you
enjoying it so far yet thoroughly
enjoyed my favorite part was they did an
episode where they kinda nemoj two older
episodes in the yeah kinda guy an
eighties bit with you know anyways other
without giving anything away with Jason
but Jason's referring to is there's an
episode that looks like an 80s sitcom
essentially with the laugh track and it
has a purpose in the story which you
would figure out if you watch it I
thought that that was very very well I
mean everything down to the music was
like you were watching an eighties show
yeah alright well duh that may be that
people had more to add over there uh
Battlestar Galactica also some people in
our audience streaming both the new and
old Battlestar Galactica series as you
know Louis the new battlestar galactica
one of my favorite shows I've never seen
the original one I started watching the
original because uh it was on netflix or
I don't know if it still is it was at
some point I started watching and I just
couldn't do it it was uh it just wasn't
doing it for me really it was all it
sits fit quite old then it it I you
maybe it just doesn't hold up you're
finding it dated in other words yeah I'm
not really into the original Star Trek
series either for
some of the same reasons um but uh hey
I'm entitled to my opinion so pleased uh
nobody shoot me over this Jason any
comments on Battlestar or Star Trek you
wanna make I can save even seen
battlestar galactica but I know I'll say
is going to you number two okay um die
your number two right let's continue
david pakman.com slash amazon is the
place to stop in before you do your
shopping on amazon